j'étais coupable je blesse que je ne
soupçonnais pas avoir il y a quelques
jours je discutais avec un ami il me
parla d'une phobie que je ne connaissais
pas et qui a pourtant fait le buzz il y
a deux ans la tripe floby latry profond
glisser la peur d'un amas de trouve bien
sûr il ya plusieurs stades de tripot
phobies comme il ya plusieurs stades
arachnophobie de toutes les phobies
mais cet ami la ressentais un très
profond malaise devant cette photo qui
pour le coup ne me fait pas grand chose
pourtant j'aime pas les à la petite
route un tout petit petit prof je me
suis alors découvert une passion pour
les phobies non mais vraiment pour moi
j'avais fait une vidéo que pour
améliorer bon on arrive nos phobies
puisque j'ai vraiment j'aimerais j'ai
vraiment très peur des araignées et
depuis ça a beaucoup mieux d'ailleurs en
fait quand tu comprends mieux à l'inseec
ça va un peu mieux sachez que quand vous
avez une phobie
ça peut venir de trois choses soit c'est
génétique c'est-à-dire que vos ancêtres
avaient peur de ce truc là pour de
bonnes raisons et ça s'est transmis de
génération en génération jusqu'à vous
soit c'est culturel c'est à dire que
c'est acquis par exemple une petite
fille dès qu'elle croise un chien dans
la rue son père l'a prend effet au
attention il ya un chien et bako cet
enfant va grandir elle aura peur des
chiens pourquoi parce que ses parents qu
il était petit on part été bien voyez
l'information suivante méfie toi des
chiens c'est dangereux ou bien troisième
raison une mauvaise expérience cap et
traumatisante vous aviez pas du tout
peur des chiens puis un jour un chien
vous a mordu au mollet très très fort
vous êtes traumatisés vous ne pouvez
plus blairer les chiens aujourd'hui on
va analyser pas mal de phobies on va
essayer de voir d'où ça vient et surtout
on va découvrir des fous bingham et mais
improbable il vous avez peut-être
découvrir que vous avez des phobies et
vous ne le saviez même pas vous n'avez
rien demandé en cliquant sur cette vidéo
malheureusement à la fin de celle ci
j'aurais peur de petites choses encore
plus qu'avant recompter toujours sur
squeeze pour vous mettre bien donc tu
parlais de la tripe aux phobies alors au
jeu flou heureusement voyez pas ce que
je vois pas ce que vraiment alors est ce
que par exemple cette image vous fait
quelque chose c'est juste des alvéoles
de ruches d'abeilles
voilà mais chez certaines personnes ça
provoque un choc émotionnel mois là ça
va honnêtement ça me fait rien ensuite
on peut aller crescendo atteint sur les
tripots fab d'un wc mais quel monde non
quelle honte de bâtard ce qu ils font
quoi ok ok sachez que si vous êtes les
pop up il ya une grande chance que ça a
été transmis par vos ancêtres mené une
étude qui a démontré qu'en fait souvent
les animaux extrêmement toxique donc
certaines araignées certains poule
eh ben ils ont sur leur corps pas mal de
trous comme ça par exemple les araignées
si les yeux ok ça fait plein de petits
ronds les poulpes c'est au niveau de
leurs tentacules il ya plein de petits
trous pareil en fait vos ancêtres ont
pensé à vous ils vous ont transmis cette
peur pour votre sécurité mais vu
qu'aujourd'hui on a plus on allait
chasser dans la mer et d'être confronté
à des poupées
ça sert à rien vous avez juste par un
passant devant une ruche d'abeilles
c'est humiliant pour draguer la fille
qu'on aime malgré les conseils qu'on
applique de la vidéo d'accord mais bon
consolez vous en vous disant que vos
ancêtres ont pensé à vous bon j'ai pas
vous me tall âgées mais des photos y
perçoivent de tripoli parce que j'ai pas
envie que c'est d'être au feuilleton sur
cette vidéo bahut fasse un gros malaise
à cause de moi mais certains s'amusent
ces petits battent à ahmed plein de
petits trous sur des parties de corps
humain je vais pas vous montrer ça parce
que même moi ça me fait un truc horrible
j'ai des frissons je trouve ça ignoble
mois j'associe un à deux petits trous à
une infection quelque chose de curieux à
la mort à un cadavre à une blessure
horrible infectés et c'est ça qui me
fait mal c'est pas les trous en soit
c'est ce qu'il ya derrière en fait c'est
le contexte tu vois ce genre quand je
vois ça gros je suis pas bien du tout
bref au nom mais qui font des visages
entier non mais ils font des visages
entier qui bouge mais c'est un sketch
gros un vrai trip hop il peut pas
blairer les fraises mec non pas qu'il
n'aime pas le coût mais il déteste
l'apparence de ces dernières puisque
c'est plein de petits trous collet il ya
des plantes par exemple regarder ça par
exemple c'est juste une petite plante et
ben ça nous met mal mais moi c'est roux
ça me fait penser à des petits verres et
samara bref passons aux phobies suivante
les amis j'ai trouvé quelques vidéos qui
parle de phobie très peu connu un bon
mois mais la mégalopole hier à dakar ok
donc ça si tu as peur d énormes chose
brochet aucune des deux ça peut venir
mais moi je suis pas hyper fan des
grands grand truc même des grands
monuments et où quand je suis devant je
me sens pas j'aime ce que c'est une
photo qu'on a mis devant moi ça crée un
sentiment bizarre un match de la peur
des serpents c'est vrai moi j'adore les
serpents mais quand il ya plusieurs
serpent ensemble tu vois pas leur tête
tu vois moi j'ai envie de trouver la
tête de chacun dans l'amas de polars
pour savoir d'où la morsure prévenir si
je mets ma main tu vois mais y en a qui
sont terrorisés devant les reptiles un
ca de toute manière nombreux tweets
proche ou pas
à la claustrophobie est-ce que vous avez
claustrophobe je pense qu'il ya
énormément de gens sont claustrophobe
mais à différentes échelles moi par
exemple quand je vais dans les
catacombes avec mamie swing c'était
génial et où on était plusieurs donc ça
allait les camps devaient passer dans
des tout petits passages j'ai vraiment
pris sur moi j'avais pas peur parce que
je pouvais quand même bouger
en fait si je lui avais dû me retrouver
dans une situation où je pouvais plus
bouger j'aurais pété un câble exemple
quand on était petit avec mon frère qui
ont joué sur un lit 6me bloqué sous la
couette jeu péter un câble mon gars mais
vraiment quelle sur un article là on
nous dit que c'est pas inné la
claustrophobie mais que c'est acquis que
dans la plupart des cas ça vient d'un
événement traumatisant que tu as vécu
comme batman qui tourne dans un trou et
se retrouve avec des chauves-souris il
aurait pu à de trop fortes derrière
batman du coup florent merci d'avoir
enfermé sous la couette de nombreuses
fois quand j'étais jeune tu as causé ce
traumatisme
merci beaucoup au jeu ça gros alors je
pense qu'on a tous un peu rapace pitot
quand tu vas dans la mer et aux doigts
de pieds touché un truc non identifié
t'es pas bien du tout je pense vraiment
que sinon patrimoine génétique et avec
ma maman se demander si a pas quelqu'un
qui est mort noyé dans ma famille parce
qu'on a vraiment peur des fonds marins
de l'eau quand vous quand tu vois pas
cela comme ça tu es au milieu de la mer
tu vois un rien de ce qu'il ya sous toit
moi ça me stresse mon gars mais un point
je savais pas que la science avait donné
un nous en fait à cette phobie light que
c'est un truc répondu que c'est ça qui
est marrant et que les phobies c'est
pour ça que cette vidéo c'est que
souvent on a peur de certains trucs et
on se doute pas que d'autres gens sont
dans le même cas que nous la chaussure
qu'il ya plein de gens qui vont réaliser
qu'ils ont des phobies et il se doutait
pas que des gens avaient peur d'un même
chose que pour l'anecdote fort boyard
j'avais dit que je voulais rien faire
dans la mer parce que vraiment je
pouvais faire des crises d'angoissé tout
si je me retrouve à devoir nager en plus
autour du forte c'est vraiment loin des
côtes du coup vu qu'ils sont à l'écouté
que il respecte les gens qu'ils invitent
bas ils m'ont fait nager dans la merde
[Musique]
à la dtn
et en sortant j'étais vraiment pas bien
du tout et ils m'ont dit athée pas bien
à l'épreuve suivante c'est parti on
enchaîne n'aura pas le temps d'avoir
peur et je vous réponds ça a marché
j'ai fait le temps de réaliser que
j'étais pas bien je pense que c'est inné
le fait d'avoir peur des fonds de 2
quand tu vois pas ce qu'il ya en dessous
tombe à saintes c'est juste bah ouais
t'es pas bien quoi il peut t'arriver un
truc tu vois pas ce qui se passe donc
bon à alors le mec va parler de la tripe
aux faux bien si vous êtes tripot fob
regarder les commentaires le temps de
passer à l'autre faux billets voilà au
cas où j'ai prié de faire du mal à
quiconque là c'est pareil c'est pas
gentil vous voyez c'est ce genre de
montage photos qui font pour créer
encore plus de malaises chez nous c'est
à dire qui te met un truc cuir jamais
sur ta peau plein de trucs comme ça
alors qu'on reste arrivera jamais à
monter une énorme affection et cta
pauline croze et et des verts sous la
peau là ça n'arrivera jamais ça non mais
ça sert à ça donc la phobie des
champignons chez basse existait ça gros
on découvre des choses échec à beaucoup
plus de gens qu'on ne le pense qu'ils
sont atteints de sa bêta en commentaire
votre phobie on vous a vu comme je
gratte des commentaires là pas du tout
grillé d'une manière bien aussi de
calculer c'est bien ça va ya plein de
phobie de gens là que le commun des
mortels ignore et que vous même vous
pouvez ignorer à voir mais c'est normal
en fait faut pas faut pas dramatiser le
truc
pourquoi parce que c'est dangereux le
vide ça c'est une phobie que tout le
monde a ses sur 100 % c'est inné nos
ancêtres ont transmis à nos ancêtres que
le vide
ben quand tu vas de dante est mort c'est
un tel sens dès lors qu'on parle de la
crau phobique et la peur du vide parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui font
l'amalgamé entre la crau phobies et le
vertige le vertige c'est pas la crau
phobie le vertige s'est pas tu as peur
tu sais tu as vraiment des pertes
d'équilibré c'est pas forcément lié au
vide à regarder je trouve un article
nous dit ce soit un problème d'oreille
interne du nerf ou descendre
vestibulaire bas donc c'est pas juste
psychologique c'est vraiment physique ça
peut venir d'un traumatisme
ancien enfant vous avez failli tomber
dans le vide lors d'une balade en
montagne ou alors ça peut être et à ce
déséquilibre entre sensations provenant
de la vue et de l'oreille interne tu
vois du vide donc tu as l'impression de
dettes dans le vide mais nantes est par
terre est honoré internet on voit les
signaux que ton corps tu envoies un mois
91 debout tout va bien mais tu as vu
tout dit ou habillées du vide là alors
je fais quoi
les tourneurs et à terre elle dit non
non rien du sol et du coup il ya un
conflit ça spoile était ma mère quand
elle était petite elle est tombée ce
gros appareil d'une chaise - une chute
nul à chier et depuis elle est
terrorisée du vide et des mouvements
brusques quand j'étais petit j'étais
allé à disneyland déjà fait le ménage
dumbo donc
juste des cabines sans une cabine et
comptable sur un bouton l'éléphant et
steve hill va à trois mètres du sol et
ma merde et j'appuie sur le bouton elle
hurlait vraiment jeté plus dans
l'attraction de mots j'étais dans
l'attraction launchpad ou en appuyant
sur un bouton
ma maman criaient dans bruxelles mais
gros thema la gueule du mec je suis
désolé c'est un peu normal d'être un peu
inconfortable voire d'avoir peur en
voyant ça c'est tout à fait normal
moi j'avoue stephen king et nous a aussi
peut-être un peu baiser la gueule
avec son/sa la marsa et c'est lié à la
peur du vide nantes a peur que le point
crack en vrai t'as juste peur que le
point kracooqas une planche qui se fait
sous toit va pas se mentir c'est ce qui
est arrivé c'est la peur des poumons en
général ou de ce pont go parce que ce
pont je te jure il fait peur à tout le
monde ici à rouina ok donc c'est même la
peur des grands grands ponts comme ça en
fait moi j'adore les ponts gros
justement je te vois j'adore les ponts
puisque souvent c'est au dessus de l'eau
et du cou
du coup fatal à sa phobie bas âge là sur
pasqua vole au dessus de logement pas
les coups je vois bien les pieds dans la
voiture qui est perçu board mec cioci
jalil a traumatisé une génération
entière et ensuite juste des trucs d'une
apparence humanoïdes mais qui sont pas
très bien fait c'est creepy frère ait
souci que ça peut venir du fait qu'à les
poupées surtout les poupées vaudou sont
associés avec la sorcellerie et du coup
ça nous met mal à l'aise
voilà il ya aussi le fait que les
poupées ont le regard fixe c'est vrai
c'est ça qui est horrible mais encore
encore nous des générations à la des
poupées stylet comme ça on est gâté quoi
mais tu imagines nos grands-parents
vieux les poupées qu'ils avaient
[Musique]
c'est normal d'avoir peur des poupées ok
elles font peur de quoi
oh non c'est tellement triste
moi c'est ma passion de ouf et galaxy
l'univers thomas pesquet oh non il y en
a qui ont peur c'est trop triste trouve
ça tellement triste moi c'est tellement
ce que j'adore ça me fait bizarre je
pensais pas qu'on peut avoir peur de
l'espace et où un an
les amis ont fini sur la meilleure
phobie l'afo buffo via make
c'est la phobie des phobies médiane et
bien les amis merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à aller mais
ciel vous a plu j'espère que vous
connaissez vos faiblesses maintenant que
vous savez de quoi vous avez peur que
vous savez sur quoi vous allez devoir
travailler dans votre vie pour combattre
ces peurs par exemple moi je vais
essayer de travailler sur ma peur là de
de la mata la sa phobie je suis content
c'est la phobie quel nom le plus le
postulat non pardon c'est à l'aso phobie
c'est mon style est sucré de voir quels
fonds bi vous avez bon après il ya des
familles dont j'ai pas parlé que sont
beaucoup plus communes comme je sais pas
moi là la phobie des aiguilles et
reptiles devoir squeeze en suggestions
sur youtube de plein de plaintes comme
ça ne vous quittons moi et mon crâne
rasé pour vivre d'autres expériences
fabuleuse attendre une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]